Governor Inslee thank you for all that
you are and all you have done to protect
preserve and love our planet Kamala
Harris came to Seattle and praised
Democrats like Governor Jay Inslee for
big government environmental policies
but thanks to those very programs
Washington State residents paid the
highest gas prices in the nation in 2021
Washington adopted cap and invest a
program intended to cap carbon emissions
and force companies to pay fees to
offset emissions at the time Governor
Inslee said minimal impact if any
pennies were talking about pennies today
the average price for a gallon of gas in
Washington is 505. but Governor Inslee
blames corporate greed we want to go to
the heart of this problem which is the
greed and avarice of these oil companies
who are still not telling us the truth
government finds a problem Market
intervention makes it worse politicians
Gaslight voters blaming corporate greed
and the cycle continues if Harris took
away anything from her visit it should
be the effects of Washington's green
energy programs are a red flag for
politicians who want to replicate them
on a national scale